all right it's September it's fall I
really want to give you guys some of
these older reviews that I've been
talking about Indiana Jones is coming
soon because it's coming out on blu-ray
on the 18th you'll get Lord of the Rings
I swear to you right now it's been on a
Metal Gear Solid kick ever since the
ground zeroes trailer and I figure why
not just play and review the entire
series so let's start out with Metal
Gear Solid 1
Metal Gear Solid infinite ammo so Metal
Gear Solid came out in 1998 for the
PlayStation 1 and it was a complete
game-changer in every way possible funny
thing is usually if a game makers making
a game years after the previous
installments of the game he'll just
remake it Metal Gear Solid would have
been a remake of Metal Gear 1 but it's
not it's actually chapter 3 the previous
installments are Metal Gear 1 and 2 that
were for the NES Laxton Metal Gear 2
came out in Japan for the NES we never
got it in the USA I played this [ __ ] at
a metal gear so when I heard they were
making Metal Gear Solid in the 90s I was
like what's happening it was Christmas
for me so I kept up on this game and I
got it the day came out and I play the
[ __ ] out of it so many times I'm gonna
give you a little bit of backstory in
Metal Gear 1 & 2 because you kind of got
to know about it I won't take too long
on it basically in Metal Gear you go to
outer heaven this place called outer
heaven because they have this nuclear
equipped walking battle tank called
Metal Gear you play a Solid Snake you go
in you find this powa named greyfox he
befriends you kind of shows you the
ropes and then you get to the end you
beat Metal Gear and then all crap your
commanding officers actually the bad
guy's name is Big Boss this is a pivotal
character in the entire Metal Gear
series Metal Gear and Metal Gear Solid
pretty much the reason I'm telling you
this big boss has this eyepatch also he
looks like a complete badass he knows
it's one of those old dude badasses
where you're like I wouldn't take you on
because you can crush me with your big
old man rock hands you beat him and then
you get to Metal Gear 2 is this uprising
in a place called Zanzibar you go there
you find out your pal gray fox has
turned to the other side so you fight
him you beat him and Big Boss is back
then you beat him in Metal Gear 2 and
you finally kill him snake goes into
retirement now we have Metal Gear Solid
for the PlayStation 1 and shits about to
get real
in the Alaskan archipelago there's a
place called Shadow Moses Island and
there's a guy who looks just like Solid
Snake his name is liquid snake and he's
taking control of it
So Solid Snake's the only man who can
take him down you're immediately
interested because you're like who is
this liquid snake why does he look just
like Solid Snake our hero and on shadow
moses you find out of course the
government is making a new Metal Gear
now the terrorists wanted so you go in
there and you enter one of the biggest
game changers in videogame history I say
that because it was a pivotal time for
games you know games were having that
3-dimensional kind of feel to it they
were using polygons now not sprites but
this was the game that really
took it to the next level if you have a
tactical espionage type game now Metal
Gear Solid paved the way for that game I
believe Tom Clancy's Rainbow six came
out before Metal Gear Solid Metal Gear
Solid was the triple threat it had great
gameplay great voice acting and it was
all cinematic it was like a playable
movie first of all the voice acting the
voice acting in this game is completely
superb again it's commonplace now you're
like oh yeah games have good voice
acting but back then they didn't you had
Castlevania Symphony of the Night I
monster you don't belong in this world
or Resident Evil what is this wow what a
mansion the [ __ ] was bad it was like
game companies were like I just throw
voices on this great doesn't have to be
good it's not like it's a movie or
anything today Okajima the brains behind
the entire Metal Gear series was like no
I'm gonna make myself a playable movie
here now there were a couple games that
did have great voice acting before Metal
Gear Solid to me blood home and legacy
Kane was the first one where I was like
this is legit voice acting but it goes
beyond the voice acting in Metal Gear
Solid games really didn't have that
cinematic experience before Metal Gear
Solid Metal Gear Solid you're playing
and you're like yeah there are cutscenes
and it has good camera angles of good
dialog and character interaction the sad
scenes and Metal Gear Solid are sad
that's what you need you know when
someone gets shot you can't just be like
oh yeah the character died whatever you
have to be like oh damn it I feel what
snake feels you know Metal Gear Solid is
the game that made cinematic style games
commonplace now of course you got to
talk about the villains in this game
usually if a game is lucky there will be
one villain that's like oh yeah that's
the coolest villain I've seen in a game
all year Metal Gear Solid had at least
three of them that I can think of the
whole collection of Foxhound baddies in
this game is the best ensemble I think
I've ever seen in a game period in terms
of bad guy ensembles but the three that
really stand out for me are we're just
gonna go straight for the throat here
liquid snake first of all the duties
intense he has a grudge against Solid
Snake he feels that Solid Snake robbed
him of all of his birth rights before he
was even born so you had that sibling
rivalry aspect in the game between solid
and liquid snake but it's not just that
petting there are bigger things going on
in Metal Gear Solid I I want to tell you
about them but I'm not going to because
it's worth playing if you haven't played
it the next one is revolver ocelot
I love Colt single-action army
revolvers the reason that this love for
those type of pistols started was
because of Metal Gear Solid revolver
ocelot comes out and he's swinging this
thing rice twirling his revolver like
he's Doc Holliday or something I was
like this dude too badass no one really
knew that revolver ocelot would be the
iconic character of the entire Metal
Gear Solid series but in terms of Metal
Gear Solid 1 he's just a really cool bad
guy another one's the cyborg ninja
there's this ninja with a katana sword
that can turn invisible like the
predator and slice the living [ __ ] out
of everyone dee dee flex bullets with
his sword that already sounds awesome he
would be cool as hell if he didn't
actually have any relevance but he does
have relevance he has relevance to snake
story he ties into the older Metal Gear
games but even if you haven't played
those games you feel the connection
between him and Solid Snake there's this
one scene this might be a spoiler but
this dude's on the ground and he's
telling snake to kill him and you have
snakes field of vision you're like oh
yeah I could just waste him right now
but if you try to kill him you hear
snake oh no I can't do it when you can
feel a connection between two characters
like that in a video game from 1998 now
I played it last week and I was like
dude this is this is shaking me up this
is rough this is real man it's heavy the
game officially hits timeless status
right there the most memorable boss
fight in the entire game is Psycho
Mantis the dudes a psychic you can't you
try to shoot at him and he'll dodge
every bullet you need to find out how to
shoot at him without him reading your
mind how you do it it's just so out of
the box you can tell Hideo Kojima the
maker of the entire series is like I
want them to think outside the box I
thought it was really cool it was really
innovative and the character was cold
he'll be like oh let me read your mind
you like custard Vanya you read your
memory card and sees what saves you have
on there but it was really cool I mean
it was it was how you use gimmicks and
games there's a cool little extra and I
even like Otto Kahn the Otto Kahn and
snake are this odd duo this odd pair
that ends up happening in Metal Gear
Solid they're going to become one of the
coolest heroic duo's ever in games but
they meet in this game and snakes all I
get a hold of yourself blow yourself
together
you know he's Ravi's the military guy
Otto Kahn's not like that he pissed
himself when the cyborg ninja was coming
towards him Otto Kahn's not the fight in
battle type of guy but I like that
because snakes like ya just take off
leave I'll take it from here
Otto comes just like 9
to help fix this because they used me so
I'm gonna help you out he could die he
knows it but he sticks around I like it
when common people step up now in terms
of the gameplay it was revolutionary
back in the day still fun to play now
but there are some features and
functions that you used too now you're
like I could go for some of those modern
functions there's no first-person mode
you can't aim at someone's head and
first-person mode and just take them out
as a third-person sneaking game and you
just one two three shoot and kill people
they did make Metal Gear Solid the Twin
Snakes for the Gamecube in which it had
Metal Gear Solid 2 s gameplay in which
you could do first-person mode very cool
feature but that's not the game I'm
reviewing the one that I consider had a
Okajima is masterpieces Metal Gear Solid
1 for the PlayStation 1 I'm reviewing
that and when people see you you're
screwed when someone sees you it's
startling is held in a Metal Gear Solid
game you're sneaking it's quiet and also
someone sees you and that exclamation
mark goes off above their head is like
right now you turn around and they're
like five guys with machine guns just
wasting you you're probably gonna die if
that happens but it is forgiving in the
sense that the alert phase only lasts
like 10 seconds you just have to be out
of their field division for 10 second
they don't know where you are for 10
seconds they'll be like alright go away
return to your positions we've already
forgotten about them we're like dogs
unrealistic yes but I'm thankful for
it's also unrealistic I can't aim at
their heads and just pick them off so
you know unrealistic balances out you
get an impressive array of weapons in
this game but let's face it your best
weapon and Metal Gear Solid is your bare
hands because the funnest way to kill
someone has come up behind him and just
put him in a headlock and break their
neck yeah before Metal Gear Solid that
really wasn't a pastime to do in a video
game but hey Metal Gear Solid brought it
to us it's been fun ever since in the
end Metal Gear Solid was revolutionary
for its time it was a triple threat this
was the game that was the reason to get
a PlayStation 1 other games did not
stand a chance against Metal Gear Solid
some of the gameplay elements are not up
to date no first-person mode and the
sniper rifle apparently when you use it
you have Parkinson's disease and a
really good and intriguing and deep
story you'll play through this game a
few times the gameplay may not be modern
but it's not completely out of date
[ __ ] either you can still play it
and have fun and the characters have
really good stories like even your
support team that you don't even meet on
the battlefield you talk to him through
the codec right now they have
fleshed-out backstories they have good
interaction with snake some like them
some don't like them and you feel the
emotion
all of it is definitely worth the 10
bucks on the PlayStation Network it cost
to download so yeah go ahead and
download that $10 well spent for sure
Metal Gear Solid definitely is awesome
tacular I put a link for a trailer from
Metal Gear Solid below I can't
understand one word in it but you watch
it and you're like I get the emotion I
get what they're going for the song is
awesome the music in Metal Gear Solid 1
is just it's great music and the song
the best is yet to come which is in this
trailer is the end credits song in Metal
Gear Solid and I love it to death I have
it on my iPod and if I'm going to plug
my own [ __ ] I put a link below to the
first video I ever actually did which
was me stitching together Metal Gear
Solid the Twin Snakes footage - the
audio for the 300 movie trailer it was a
big thing to do back in 2006 so I did it
and it was it was fun but if you have to
pick one video to watch watch the
trailer - Metal Gear Solid because it's
great so your favorite video game
villain of all time what is it whatever
it may be comment below let me know and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you